don't Focus too much on where you are
now because guess what your potential
expands As you move towards it you know
what that means it means you can never
know what your potential is because as
you move towards it it expands so you
may think I just want to get a job on a
kitchen I'd love to work in the kitchen
cooking and as you start if you think
actually I'd like to be the senior Chef
in this kitchen and that will move to I
want my own restaurant I want my own
cookery book I want my own cookery
program there's nothing wrong with any
of that one of my clients just wanted to
be a vet that's all she wanted to be but
she couldn't be a vet because she was
asked to leave veterinary school twice I
said look it isn't black or white why do
you want to be a veteran I love animals
I just want to work with animals and so
I spoke to her and asked her to consider
working in a charity for animals and
then she trained to be an animal
behavioral expert and then she got her
own show so her 10 Council went from
working in this animal rescue center
being paid to work in an animal rescue
center training to be an animal
behavioral expert all because that was
what her heart wanted to do that's all
she ever wanted to do keep thinking
about your goals use that mood one
remember your potential expands As you
move towards it where you are now it
doesn't matter you have no idea what
your potential is because it's going to
move as you move towards it start stop
focusing on 10-year goals and worry
about what's in front of you right now I
think people spend too much time
worrying about their their life plan
about their five-year goals their
10-year goals think about where you were
10 years ago who were you what were your
goals what did you think was possible 10
years ago you know I'm I'm 40 how old am
I Nina 40 41 am I 41. I'm 42 soon wow so
42 when I was 32 did I predict that I'd
be here no think about where you were 10
years ago could you with any
degree of confidence say this is where
I'm going to be in 10 years and and this
is what ended up happening there's no
way like you from 10 years ago has no
idea what you're capable of and and
that's the point like if growing if
you're learning if you're improving if
you're getting better then you have no
idea what you're capable of doing in the
10-year window
you just don't all you can do is the
best guess if you're going to project
forward 10 years it's the best guess of
where you're at right now and it can
still be a useful exercise
to come up with a list of ideas and
goals of where you want to be in five
years or ten years can still be a useful
exercise for where you are right now the
challenge with it and why I'm not a huge
fan of it is because it often then leads
to you locking yourself in because if
you are growing and you're learning and
you're improving and you're getting
better you're watching videos like this
you care about you know proving yourself
then you honestly should jump off your
10-year goals two years in
16 months in maybe three months in
because you've learned something new and
now this is a better path for you
if you can with precision
hit your 10-year goals then I think
you're thinking small
you're thinking small you're living a
boxed in life you know you're uh your
at a very boring job and you know the
path up and that's where you're going to
be in 10 years I think if you love your
life and you're learning and you're
growing you have no idea where you're
capable of in the 10 year window okay so
if 10 year goals aren't the answer then
then what's the answer how do I get some
kind of Direction and Clarity for what I
should do with my life well I divide
into two things one is you've got your
purpose and then you've got what's in
front of you so the purpose is something
that will will never change your I
believe your purpose comes from your
pain so two of the most important
exercises you can ever do is to figure
out your who and your why and I go
through this and build to serve my book
but your who is your single most
important core value mine is believe
figure out what yours is that gives you
Clarity for the rest of your life what I
want to create is things that help me
believe in myself more and then I can
spread more belief to the world as well
right what is your single most important
core value if you feel lost you're
struggling you feel like you're pulled
in a million different directions
everybody's got some agenda for your
time your challenge is you don't know
what you stand for so figure that out
your single most important value you're
who your why is your purpose your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled with the most is the thing
you want to help other people through
whatever challenges hurdles that you
overcome the most important ones at the
times when you felt the most useless as
a human there are other people right now
millions of people right now who are
struggling with that same exact thing
and your purpose is to help them not
feel as isolated as a loan and help them
not struggle as much so for me it was
helping entrepreneurs because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur so
belief plus entrepreneurship right
because that's my who and my why so for
you what is your single most important
core value and then what is your pain
that you you experience the most and in
that combination is what you'll love
doing for the rest of your life for the
rest of your life they all be I'll be
120 years old 200 years old who knows
how long we'll be living and I'll still
love
believing in entrepreneurs forever it
never gets old it doesn't go away if
anything it only gets stronger and
that's why I think it's one of the most
important exercises not the most
important two exercises you can ever do
in your life because it helps you
understand your life going backwards but
more importantly that helps you plan a
better life going forward
who do you want to be what do you what
is the work that you want to do that
will be of service and in helping others
and make you feel like your life has
meaning
and allow you to be proud of yourself
that is a high level
of what you want to do for the rest of
your life figuring out your who and your
why right most more core value and your
your purpose okay it doesn't really give
a lot of guidance of like what exactly
to do right it doesn't dive into a lot
of the tactics like okay what do I wake
up and do today if I want to believe in
entrepreneurs it's still pretty big it's
still a pretty wide uh purpose a pretty
wide Mission what do I wanna what do I
actually want to do today well that's
where you connect to
whatever's in front of you right now
what are you most attached to what are
you most emotional about what is your
heart telling you to go off and do and
less about 10 in 10 years I want to have
a New York Times best-selling book or
insert whatever you know goal that you
think is Meaningful to you and much more
about what would make me come alive
right now and Trust in that instinct so
right now it's making YouTube videos so
we're in the car we're on the way to
Costco he's got some stuff to buy and
I'm making videos because I feel like
this matters because this is going to
reach somebody because not just all my
videos but this video right now this one
specifically maybe for you this is this
is the moment where things shift and
change maybe this is the one that gives
you the permission to go and do
something bigger maybe it gives you the
confidence or the courage to say yes to
the idea that you've got in the back of
your mind that you've been delaying a
little bit too long on procrastinating a
little bit too long on fearful that it
won't work out and this is the video
that helps you push forward and do it at
least that's what I'm telling myself
that for one person this is gonna be the
video that makes a change that's how I
am able to to get up and do these things
otherwise
you land in the land and what's the
point
and if you're stuck in what's the point
line then you don't make anything that's
that's the brakes on everything that you
want out of life and so you've got your
vision and you've got your purpose what
are you trying to accomplish right
you've got your most important core
value and then you've got what's in
front of you what do you work on right
now and how excited are you buying a lot
of times people come to me and they've
got their list of all the things that
they could do I could do this or I could
do that or I could do this what are you
most excited by how many of those things
on your list are because you think you
should do them or because somebody told
you that you should do them versus
you're actually jazzed about doing it
when I first started doing videos I
sucked at it
uh being introverted and shy and not
knowing any of the technical stuff and
the gear and I really struggled at it
and and there was nothing on paper
um that would have led itself to me
being a content creator right of the
career tests or whatever would never
have pointed towards something like this
but I made a video because I felt like
it
and I liked it I wasn't very good at it
I wasn't getting any results from it but
I liked it I enjoyed it and that is the
thing that allowed me to keep going so
out of all the things that are on your
list or ideas what do you feel most
attached to what are you most energetic
by what would get you going that it
doesn't feel like work to show up and do
these things but it's actually fun the
process not just the result of helping
somebody but the actual process of doing
the the work feels good to you it's
exciting to you what is that thing and
then go do it and if you can match those
two things
setting setting goals is relatively easy
saying you want to have a New York Times
best-selling book in the next 10 years
it's an e-goal to pick the problem with
it is that you're not emotionally
connected to it enough it doesn't mean
enough to you what does that actually
mean
and it's still set by a person who's not
capable of thinking on the 10-year
Horizon because you're going to be a
different person 10 years from now
you'll still have the same core values
but you're going to be stronger you're
going to know more you have a lot more
experience you get the world will be
different the opportunities will be
completely different right where was I
10 years ago on YouTube
uh not very far a couple hundred
subscribers when I say I'm gonna have
three million subscribers on my YouTube
channel no I didn't think that was
possible with being a YouTuber wasn't
even a thing
so you don't know what the world holds
for you so you've got your most
important core value
you're who you've got your purpose which
is your why that comes from your pain
and then you've got what's in front of
you right
and don't over judge and over analyze
you don't have the next 18 steps lined
up for yourself for what you should be
doing with your life because nobody's
got that and if you've got that then
you're thinking small because you don't
know what you're capable of so don't
over stress Don't over analyze and the
most important thing is take that if
you've done the work on the high level
to figure out your who and your why
then what's in front of you right now
that you're excited about that you could
do that is of service to other people
and get going
because you've got the heart you've got
the energy you've got the capability
you've got the passion you've got the
desire and the willingness to serve
you just gotta get out and start doing
it
get going
belief
foreign
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
so the first thing that people who are
incredibly successful do is they do what
they hate they are fully prepared to do
what they hate to get to where they want
to be and and people who fail they will
give up their dream before they do what
they hate to do people who are very
successful they never ever ever wait for
motivation they do it
because when you do it you become
motivated a great writer won't go well I
just wait till I'm really motivated to
start writing this book no they get up
at four in the morning they don't want
to and they start to write and then of
course they become motivated you wake up
in the morning and you go you're not
going to go yay it's 5am I'm putting on
my running shoes and going for a walk up
Laurel Canyon
of course you're not going to do that
you're going to wake up and go God I
really hate working out but Marissa said
successful people do what they hate to
get to where they want to be of course
the wonderful thing is that when you do
what you hate first enough times it
starts to become natural like I've got
to do my taxes I'll do that first thing
I've got to confront someone and I'll do
it first and so I still to this day wake
up and think oh I don't really want to
do that so I'm going to do it first
because what I do want is to belong to
that group of very very successful
people so I know what the membership is
and everything I don't want to do
something I think I don't want to do it
but what I do want is to belong to that
group so I'm doing it first and it's
it's a great way of thinking because it
starts to move you around wanting to do
it for all the right reasons many many
years ago I'm I met someone who wanted
to be a rock star that was his ambition
actually particularly wanted to be a
drummer and he was a very young married
man with two children to support
and he was going for a lot of auditions
and of course all the auditions take
place during the day and every time he
had a job they wouldn't let him take
time off so he decided he would have to
work nights in order to audition during
the day and the only job he could get
was a job he hated he was a taxi driver
and he hated it but he did it but he
just wasn't making enough money so he
thought okay I'll have to work in
McDonald's I get more money I can work
nights I'm free to audition and about a
month before he'd applied to work at
McDonald's he'd been for an audition to
be a drama in a band he didn't know who
the band was and the day he was due to
start working at McDonald's which he
absolutely hated even the thought of he
got a call to go you know that band you
auditioned for was actually simple minds
and now you're the drama and Simple
Minds that he never worked in McDonald's
or drove a cab again for the rest of his
life but when he told people that story
they'd all go oh I would never work in
McDonald's oh my God I'd never degrade
Myself by driving a around London and
I'm like
don't you think you're missing the point
his ability to do what he hated is what
made him a rock star because he had to
have his days free to rehearse and
audition but if he had your mindset I'd
never do that he would never be a
multi-millionaire rock star it was
because he was fully prepared to do what
he hated to swallow his pride to keep
his vision in mind I want to be a rock
star I must be free for auditions
how can I do that well I have to work as
a cab driver and in a fast food
restaurant which I hate but I'm going to
do it because it's going to take me to
my goal and it did but the people who
laughed him and said I wouldn't do that
none of them are Rockstar you mentioned
something about
leaning into the feelings until you're
no longer need to feel them or until
they go away feel the feeling and it no
longer requires to be felt why do we why
should we do that so give an example of
this okay so let's imagine you you and
your ex-wife are not getting on and you
have a feeling of Rage about the fact
that she's trying to get your kid to
call the new guy daddy and she's
blocking you out and you feel so angry
you think I mustn't feel angry you know
she's doing it for the interest of my
kid or and so I just drink the anger and
I drink the anger and you see with the
feeling it's the most real thing you
have a feeling is like a little kid and
a class going notice me I'm over here
and if you don't they get more and more
out of control and so when you don't
acknowledge your feelings they regroup
and they regroup until they become
outrage rage coming out and then
suddenly they go a bit crazy in the car
park of the store or the line of a store
because the mind says I've got all this
rage wants to come out someone just cut
in to the Line Take It Out On them and
it's so ineffective because I have
something I call
Triple A which is be aware of your
feeling most people have no idea what
they feel they got I shouldn't feel
jealous I shouldn't feel envious I
shouldn't be furious with this kid who's
keeping me up all night so they're not
aware of it they certainly can't accept
and they never get to articulate if you
can say you know my wife's a good person
but actually I'm furious with what she's
doing it really hurts my feelings that's
why group therapy in places like AAA the
good thing is you get to say sometimes I
could quite cheerfully
hurt my wife I'm not going to but I feel
like oh yeah I feel like that too
because when you can express your
feeling it goes away it goes away
immediately but when you educate it yeah
even to yourself so if your
mother-in-law is the absolute somehow
and you can't say by the way Dorothy you
are the most horrible mother-in-law in
the world
but you just go and shut yourself in the
bathroom turn on the Taps flush it on it
and say Dorothy is a really unpleasant
mother-in-law
I feel so much better because you're not
saying it to them it's like feelings are
like gas they're in or they're out and
they hurt much more when you keep them
in and you want to let them out maybe it
has to be not obviously right in the
middle of a meeting but when you keep
stuffing it causes you pain you have to
understand a bit more of psychology
because humans are hardwired to recreate
what they know we like what's familiar
even if that's very even if it's very
bad if I've never had money and I win
the lottery I'm going to get rid of it
or if I've never had love and you love
me I'm going to reject you because it's
so unfamiliar if I've had a dad who
calls me an idiot and worthless guess
what kind of guy I like that's it
because when I meet them I go oh I feel
like I've known this guy my whole life
we just clicked and they think oh my God
it's because he's my dad but I've been
sleeping with them for six months I
don't know what to do with that now
because we are wired to like what is
familiar and to resist what's unfamiliar
and that's what kept us alive when we
lived in water didn't go a bit bored
with this group I think I'll go outside
the water City and find another tribe
because they might have killed you so we
have this wiring that says run towards
what's familiar and run away from what's
unfamiliar
but the very good news is you can make
anything familiar and the most important
thing to make familiar is praising
yourself that's if you could just do
that that in itself would change how so
your entire life how do you praise
yourself
well you get out in the morning and go
I'm a good person I have a skill I have
a town I have something to offer the
world I'm here for a reason you look in
the mirror and go oh there you are
you're a good person you got a good
heart you know the most important way to
answer that question is this
what did you always want your dad to
tell you even if you never had a dad if
you had a dad a good dad what would he
have said what would your mama said what
would a nice teacher have said to you
and it would be something like this I'm
proud of you
you're a good son I'm so glad I'm your
dad how lucky I got to have you and a
teacher would say you're such a smart
kid what a joy it is to teach you
because you're smart and we all want to
hear the same stuff I love you I'm proud
of you you're interesting you're a great
company nobody needs to hear on the best
dentist in Beverly Hills because that
doesn't work it's emotions and many of
my clients
their mother might be dead but they're
still trying to get her to approve of
them dad's living in another country but
they're still working to make him like
them
and you know the most important thing is
you like you your beliefs affect your
world you believe certainly affect your
biochemistry I've had women of 58 say
could you make me pregnant I go I know
you it's too late why did you wait 30
years but the mind will follow your
instructions and it's very important to
give yourself the right and such of
course they're our limit you can't tell
yourself you're going to be an astronaut
and people said I want to be a
millionaire like what are you going to
do to be a millionaire you can't go
wrong with sit at home and that's the
problem with the secret attract Millions
to you what are you going to do for
these ones I want to be have a six-pack
you do need to go to the gym I want to
have great health well stop eating pizza
and eat better food but once you get the
mind to want it it's actually easy but
when people say to me I want to be a
millionaire then we tell them well any
goal of significance requires you to
learn something new but then they have a
fear of learning and and of course
you're right the women will come in and
go I want this you have to look at the
blocks the number one block is the fear
of rejection if I make it I might get
rejected if I find love they might leave
if I make all that money people won't
like me anymore so you've got to smash
out of the ballpark the fear of
rejection you've got to smash out the
second belief that says it's all easy I
remember Luther Vandross saying you know
people say I'm an overnight success I
sang Jingles for KFC for 12 years
it was a long overnight so you do have
to also have that desire
I mean for me you know I speak in public
I write books always aware that
somebody's going to hate your book I
don't like it I'm like oh that's okay
they can't reject me they might reject
my book most people happen to love them
but to get anywhere in life
you have to get over the fear of
rejection
because people think they're going to
die from rejection but they really do
people come in and they describe you
know I really want to be successful but
I'd love to be healthier but I want to
find love but I can't get pregnant
because
and the first thing we do is investigate
like a good detective a detective will
lay out pictures and go what's going on
here and they make sense of it and very
much the same so people come to me again
I've got unexplained infertility what is
that it went well there's a clue in the
in the in the description it is
unexplained nobody knows your husband's
got crack sperm that swims straight and
plenty of it you've got great eggs great
Fallopian tubes perfect womb but you
can't get pregnant because the The
Unexplained is here
and many people when they're younger
will say this if I got pregnant my dad
would kill me oh my God if I got
pregnant with the end of the world and I
remember when I was 17 thinking I was
pregnant oh my God no disaster oh my God
my dad will be so upset devastated when
I wasn't I went on thank you God yes Joy
but you see the Mind listens to
everything you say the mind is always
switched on and it records everything
and it never forgets so
in a moment of absolute Terror or fear
or pain or anxiety there's something
called an imprint it goes in
so a child whose mother says that cat
will scratch you and give you blood
poisoning or that dog's gonna bite you
or that's a dangerous person or you know
I went to a little kid who had a
terrible fear of monsters under the bed
turned out his dad used to say you'll
get run over if you do that you'll kill
yourself if you do that you'll drown if
you do that turned out his dad was the
monster because he was scaring him all
the time so you get a young person can
be an adult and you get an imprint and
what we do is investigate where where
did this imprint happen and when we've
got the imprint which is very easy you
can ask questions to get the imprint you
can listen to the client's Story the one
who said my mum used to cry when I
brought up food and so happy when I ate
or you can use hypnosis and go back like
that and the reason I love hypnosis so
much is you go to the imprint you know
people come to see me within five
minutes they have the imprint there's no
oh how does that make you feel and how
do you feel now and let's talk more
about that and come back next Wednesday
at four and we'll keep this going
because studies now say that's that's
actually the worst thing you can do
because you just keep the story alive so
we do the investigator we find the
imprint
and then we we interpret it what does
that mean why do you think you know your
dad telling all these stories would now
leave you to have this monster under
your bed why do you think
15 being terrified of being pregnant
could possibly mean that today you've
got an explainability and they work it
out they go yeah now you say that if I
look at those scenes and look at this
Scene It will make sense and then you
interrupt the belief massively and then
you install a brand new belief you know
you're getting pregnant like a high
school kid on their first day you're
super fertile you've got crack grade ax
your husband's got the SAS of sperm and
it's gonna Collide so you bring in the
very powerful language and you are going
to make it grade a baby because of
course because I want to be pregnant I'm
like no you don't you want to make a
baby that you carry to full term I have
been pregnant eight times
you want a perfect bouncing healthy baby
so it's another example of not telling
your mind what you want so the
combination of the imprint the
investigate the interpret the interrupt
and the install
is so powerfully transformational when
you focus on the worst possible outcome
you actually feel as if you are in that
worst possible outcome the only way to
overcome a fear is instead of focusing
on the worst possible outcome to focus
on the best possible outcome I'm driving
it's foggy it's dark it's icy I might
skid off the road and kill myself or I'm
driving very carefully I'm driving very
slowly I'm driving very cautiously
because I'm going to be safe and I'm
going to get home see that's the
difference you just have to give
yourself different beliefs the thing
with fear always is you have two choices
rationalize where you feel so terrible
or tool yourself out when I was on the
beach with my daughter and there was a
big dog and it was quite a scary dog and
she didn't like this dog and I said to
you know darling when you don't like a
dog you get very scared and the dog
doesn't like it either and he gets
scared so when you see a scary dog turn
your back to it don't look at it because
when you look at it you're challenging
it and that's hard to do to turn your
back on a door but if you turn your back
it's not a challenge and she understood
that and I was always teaching her when
you have a fear you have a choice oh my
God that dog's going to bite me attack
me hurt me or I'm going to talk myself
I'm going to turn away I'm going to
breathe they're going to be really calm
and that dogs is going to go on its way
and it's the same with everything in
life to do with fear rationalize why you
feel so fearful or
talk yourself out of it are we fine this
is okay everything's gonna work out
perfectly I'm okay all of these fears
hold you back and they don't have to
because every fear you go through
teaches you something you see if you go
to a fun phone go to those loop the loop
rides you can scream in Terror or you
can scream in excitement and the fact
that people put themselves through those
rights means that at some level we quite
like fear it challenges us to do more it
challenges us to grow more so don't fear
fear remember the only fear to fear is
fear itself I find that even with cancer
if you have that belief I'm going to try
all this stuff but it won't work and you
know it's I'm riddled with it and
there's no hope and they start to read
all these terrible diagnoses I mean in
England you are not allowed to say to
someone you've got 10 months to live
because that's what happens they turn
into the 10 months you cannot diagnose
what do they tell them they just say you
know we're going to do this and this and
you may not survive this but you could
and and in the same way that if you're
having surgery and they go this is a
complete mess in here there's just no
way even in surgery subconscious is
hearing what's going on around you and
there are many people who come out of a
coma who said you know I heard
everything the hearing is the last thing
to go and so if you make a choice to
talk to yourself better
you can bounce back you might as well
use your mind as much as you possibly
can to be well we tell ourselves the
story we play the only part we've ever
known and then that part becomes our own
and we don't know how to separate it and
so we'll come in with their story and
they go well you know I nearly I was a
newborn baby and my mum told me that I
was only like two pounds I nearly died
they had to drop milk I mean with a
dropper and I remember my mum telling me
she used to cry every time I got weighed
or if she fed me when I threw up they
would get so upset because I could die
like okay and now you're 600 pounds
because you keep telling yourself that
story
and people tell themselves the story
until it validates why you know my dad
didn't love me he left before I was born
he never came to see me but he had
another kid that you treat like Jesus
bought him everything game boys clothes
so if my dad didn't love me I'm not
lovable and you have to go but that was
then your dad was an idiot that's
nothing to do with whether you can find
love or not
the clients tell themselves this story
and they don't understand that at any
age you can go well I I think it's time
for a new story and so my job is to
first of all find out where where you
know they're coming to go I don't know
why I do this I guess I'm just messed up
I don't know why I can't speak but I've
always been that way going no no baby
looks away when you look at them in the
house or no baby goes don't look at me
I'm having a bad hair day we're all born
with so much confidence you have four
children they never gonna I can't get a
banana in my mouth I I can't get to
grips with this walking reaching they're
they're wired to go for something but a
lot of damage is done very early and and
I see that all the time really silly
things like people coming and going you
know I can't ask for money and then our
TT has what I call interruptions or
after they've gone back
they have to then say but that's not me
because and that can't be me because and
that won't be me
ever again and what that does is it
starts to change the neurons it's
actually called
neuroplasticity it starts to change the
way the brain is wired they stop
thinking the way they thought as a child
and put into place different beliefs and
then they're forever changed and it's
amazing to see it in action you always
have a choice
your mind talks to your body all the
time that's its job and your job
is to tell your mind what you want I
want perfect health
I don't do illness I do Wellness
everything I do is perfect you know I
was at a conference reasoning someone
around them oh my God I'm so glad I
listened to your audio because you know
I have four hours of sleep and I tell my
mind I'm having eight and I thought I
should do that I'm teaching people this
I forgot I can do that too tell my mind
I've had eight hours sleep tell my mind
I feel amazing tell my mind when I'm
working out my body loves this my
muscles love this I can do a bit more
rather than go oh it all aches and I
hate doing this and I could be a home
watching TV
so just to be very clear your mind's job
is to do what you tell it and your job
should you choose to accept is to tell
it great things amazing things
I'm not aging I'm saging I'm and I'm
embodying Wellness I have perfect
balance you can choose
not only does the mind tell the body
what to do it also interrupts the
signals coming back from the body I've
got this crippling thumping headache and
become what I've got a little niggle in
my head but I'm really too busy to
notice it I'm in agony no you've just
had a little shot that's not Agony this
commute is hell no hell is not having a
car or any gas and looking at people or
taking three buses to do your commute
being in this store is torture no
when you go to Africa and you see they
don't have any stores and the ones who
do have no food and you're never again
standing rafts and go this is a
nightmare it's hell grocery shopping if
you have money in your wallet to buy
food with people that love you that is
so far beyond hell but people use these
words it's killing me it's a disaster
it's a nightmare and also whenever
anyone does anything wrong we go what's
wrong with you we should say what
happened to you what happened to you and
they'll go well you know my mom always
said she didn't want a girl boy she
wanted a girl and I've been brought up
give an example I had a city Trader as a
client who really had problems trading
and his boss said you know he's the best
Trader but he's so nervous and when I
worked with him he was when he was a kid
his parents had two girls and then him
and he would smash his tongue guitars
are going to go what's wrong with you
look at your sisters just combing their
doll's hair and they're so good and why
are you so aggressive and for you I
can't go well because I have something
called testosterone and they don't and
I'm designed to run and jump and hunt
and fish and I gotta learn what to do
with aggression smashing my cars
together is good for me he didn't
four-year-old doesn't have anything
because they live in the world yeah they
just live in a world of feeling not
logic and he said I never realized just
spent my whole life thinking something's
wrong with me because my parents would
say everything comes what's wrong with
you look how neat it is they don't get
Peas on the floor when they eat and he
said I heard it every day until I formed
a belief something's wrong with her he
didn't date women because he thought
well I should be like one but I want to
be like a man and that session totally
turned him around he said it was like he
someone had sprayed it with pheromones
because he went out that night when we
were detaching them or something like a
magnet but he just got rid of the
feeling of something's wrong with me
because most people do walk around
getting something's wrong with me I'm
just majorly messed up
and you can't heal no one understands me
and no one gets you yeah and I don't
understand me and if I don't understand
me how can you and why should I even be
here yeah because you can't hear what
you can't understand and so all the
treating the symptom is like putting a
Band-Aid on an infection it doesn't when
you understand it you can totally change
your perception of what it is because
events actually don't affect you but the
meaning you attaches and does the story
We Tell ourselves the story we have a
great fear of rejection which is not
surprising because when we're born we
have two drivers find connection
avoid rejection after all if a mother
rejects a child if a lion rejects the
cob he's not going to be adopted it will
die yeah or it just starves to death and
so we know innately that our Survival on
the planet is linked to not being
rejected
and not that long ago you would have
died from rejection you know in in a
thousand years ago when they banished
you outside the walls of the city or you
marooned a difficult sailor or you cast
someone out of the community but you
pretty much died there was nothing out
there but Purgatory so we have a wiring
that says rejection will kill me
and that's why you have the fear but
when you can dialogue with no it feels
like it will kill me it can't kill me
because no girl can reject me unless I
give her my permission right give them
my power you can't reject me unless I
agree with everything I don't like you
because you got short hair I don't like
your shirt I don't like you because
you're white not white tall short
glasses not
but when you say you can't reject me I'm
I can't be rejected because the only
person you can reject me is me you can
talk to girls realizing even if they say
no you're not my type I'm with someone
no thanks or even ooh not no they can
only reject you if you let that in and
we look at someone like James Corden
who's certainly not gorgeous but women
love him because he's funny so funny and
you know we like warm people you know
the the packaging is all very nice well
as we'll have a great packaging a great
wrapper and it'll but they're unhappy
and so our greatest fear is to be
rejected but the truth is in 2018 you
could live in this apartment have Amazon
over your groceries never see a soul and
you probably live until you're 106. yeah
wouldn't I advise it but we don't die of
rejection anymore but we still feel like
we will and all schools should be
teaching kids you cannot be rejected you
can ask for a pay rise you can ask for
crowdfunding you can go to someone go
here's my idea you can write a book
speak in public because with a lot of
actors who say I'm so scared of
rejection I'm like well how are you
going to be an actor then
you and I write books for everyone who
loves it there's going to be the odd
person because I hate this book and I
hate that writer too but we don't let it
in we have to laugh about it when you
give a YouTube talk I mean I've got one
of my talks about like three million
views and there's a few and they're
going I hate to stuck up English
um snob but they don't know me because
that's not me at all but I don't go my
God I can never write another book I can
I'm okay because I don't let it in
because the only opinion that matters is
my opinion I know I'm not a stuck-up
English snob so that can't hurt me in
powerful language you can never say you
can fall you're going to mess that up
you're going to ruin everything
that's just not going to work out you
have to say the opposite okay I've only
got 10 minutes to prepare my speech I
only need 10 minutes I've only got 10
minutes to get there that's exactly how
much time I need and if I'm late I
wasn't supposed to be there on time I
have a belief now when I get to a party
late it's because it wasn't I wasn't
meant to get there early I no longer go
my God I'm so late this is going to be
terrible in fact I was recently going in
a cab across town to get a train to work
with a football team and we got stuck in
traffic and so I was playing a game I
thought oh my God I'm going to miss the
train this is terrible I'm going to ruin
my reputation the team are going to be
so upset and I felt really sick and then
I started to say the trains run every 20
minutes it doesn't matter
what's 20 minutes my material is so
great they have lots of time off well
they're finished
practicing at three o'clock and and it
was fine so all the way there I was
playing a game
and I actually got the Train on time but
they really wouldn't have minded but I
could have ruined my day made myself
panicky and sweaty but going oh my God I
haven't got enough time and now it's all
ruined and it's never ruined you can
come back from anything and then I
worked with a client who had cancer and
had to go into this MRI scanner and
every time I saw him he's like I can't I
can't do it I can't get in that scanner
and I wanted I said well I feel like I'm
in my coffin I feel like it's a
premonition of my death and I get in
this scanner I think well I've got
cancer and I'm going to die and what is
it will I freak out I press the button I
have to come out and they keep saying
look you've got to go on I can't even be
in there for two seconds which is not
true I can't do it for even a second he
probably was in there for a few minutes
I said look the words you say to
yourself in that scanner this is a
premonition of my death I feel like I'm
in a coffin I feel like I'm suffocating
and I can't do it that's a blueprint and
your mind doesn't like those words so
how about these words how about saying
I'm in my bed at home and I'm just so
chilled and I could lie here for hours
I'm chilled I'm relaxed I'm blissed out
you must use words that make a picture
you can't go oh I'm okay really I'm
quite good I'm not bad this is okay
because when I say the words okay not
bad where's the picture
there's no pictures what I call fluff
when you say I'm chilled I'm blissed out
I'm ecstatic I'm just lying here and I
could do this for hours it's just so
cool the Mind goes you're right and when
you go I'm in a coffin and I'm
suffocating the Mind goes you're right
see here's a great thing you can choose
any words you like you can go well we're
all going to be negative and this house
is going to be positive that's your
choice you know what you can't choose
what you do to yourself when you say I'm
an idiot I'm a I'm a I've
got rocks for brains everything goes
wrong who would ever like me I've got
cellular I'm a single parent I've got no
chance blah blah blah I didn't go to
college so I couldn't possibly do what
you do I got kicked out of college by
the way so you can definitely do what I
do and it was the best thing that ever
happened to me I can look at my life and
say being fired being dumped and being
kicked out of college thank you God for
putting that in up to me because it
changed my life it was the best thing
rejection has been one of the best
things that ever happened to me being
the least favorite kid if I could have
my life again I'd go back and be the
least favorite kid because I thought I'm
going to show my parents that I'm
something and if I was a favorite I
wouldn't have done that I would have had
a totally different life here's some
things I want to start doing today right
now that will build your self-esteem
super fast the number one thing
is to praise yourself there is nothing
nothing
that will build your self-esteem like
praise but your Praises if you have a
Shoppers and he said oh you look really
great in the outfit yeah it suits you
you must buy it they have an agenda if
your boss says you're amazing at your
job but I need to give you work to do
over the weekend they have an agenda
someone dating you might have an agenda
and your mind knows that when when you
say I'm great at my job I'm smart I'm
kind I'm nice people like me there is no
agenda unfortunately when you go and
rubbish at my job I'm boring I always
mess up and I have no friends your mind
lets that into because your mind doesn't
really care if what you say is right or
wrong good or bad healthy or unhealthy
let me prove that to you I want you to
put your hand in front of your face like
that I want you to close your eyes I
want you to imagine you have a big fat
juicy lemon and I want you to breathe in
that wonderful lemon smell and just
squeeze it a bit and feel that wonderful
lemon texture because nothing quite
smells like a lemon so still really
believing you have half a lemon in your
hand
open your mouth
shove that lemon in there cram that half
a lemon into your mouth and start
chewing and sucking and biting and
swallowing the flesh keep sucking all
that lemon flesh into your mouth bite it
chew it suck out the juice
and you'll notice what is happening is
your body is responding to a thought as
if it's a fact
your body is responding to the image and
thought of eating a lemon as if you are
actually eating a lemon and it's making
a saliva because thoughts are things
and every thought you have
a physical reaction in your body and an
emotional response to when you think I
don't have friends I can't talk to
people I can't take things back to a
store I can't ask for special treatment
I don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say
oh I can talk to anyone I'm an
interesting person I'm warm and friendly
people like me and I can make eye
contact I'm good at my job I can ask
someone out on a date I can tell the
person I'm involved with what I need
your mind accepts that too and someone
recently said they keep a lemon on their
desk now and look at it every day I'm
sure they change every month because
that lemon reminds them every day that
they are responsible for what they think
and feel and you know responsibility
that word means an ability to respond
so I want you to start to praise
yourself I want you to wake up in the
morning the first thing you go is I like
myself you do know don't you that people
who are critical
have so much criticism reserve for
themselves they actively dislike
themselves and you're actually showing
me and the entire office that you really
don't like yourself by critiquing me
yeah by creating You're just showing me
yeah critical people always have
criticism reserved for themselves they
are full of self-criticism but they
reflect it out and Superior people and
happy people always praise and people
who feel inadequate always criticize
because criticize Withers you and praise
builds you up and if you can use those
five techniques thanks for sharing could
you repeat that are you trying to hurt
my feelings won't work I'm not letting
it in since we're sharing did you know
what is running your critical Behavior
you don't let it in and being able to
not let in criticism that too will
change your life it it makes you
bulletproof you can't stop moving mean
and having a horrible day and we now
have trolling which is becoming an
epidemic so it's actually worse our kids
used to get bullied at school and go
home to a sanction another bullet online
now they're bullied online on the phone
and it's it never ends and they feel
really attacked and see when you find
trolls they're usually really miserable
and unhappy but they love the power
because they have no power they live on
their own or with their mum they have no
life I mean we had a terrible situation
in England where somebody was trolling
this person whose childhood of being
kidnapped and when they exposed her she
killed herself which was a terrible
thing for her but obviously her sense of
shame that she was outed and to kill
herself but she must have felt terrible
I felt so sorry for her but she was very
issues in her trolling but that's a
really unhappy person she needed a lot
of help but when you can teach people to
come back from criticism without
fighting or going well I hate you too or
you're a little shut up or crying when
you can just teach them look
I'm not letting it it's like if I try to
give you a gift you go and I don't need
that gift I'm holding the gift I can't
give you something if you don't take it
I can't serve papers on you unless you
accept them I can't serve a volunteer
unless you volley it back so when you
learn that people can try and give you
anything but if you don't accept it
you haven't let it in and if you don't
let it in you can't hurt you it just
hurts the person who's left holding it
how do you help people establish meaning
behind when I wrote a book called I'm
enough and we have a program that I'm
enough and what that does is it takes
you the process of where does this come
from you're not born with this belief
how did you get it and when they
discover how they got it they're able to
give it up one of my first ever clients
was this beautiful woman very hard to
believe which is I can never make a
relationship last
and it sounds so silly but she said that
Dad you say to every day you'll never
ever find anyone that loves you like me
nobody could love you like me you'll
never find the kind of love that I have
and
he programmed when you label someone you
limit them so now she's got an imprint
I'm never going to find a love like this
love and guess what she never found love
like that and all you have to do as a
parent you should say I love you because
you're lovable
and all your life you'll find love like
this love because you're worth it so
it's little tiny adjustments that have
the most profound effect on people and
it's never too late to say I'm enough I
can find love and now if you give
someone the power to make you feel good
you give them the power to make you feel
bad and if you do it to yourself
you feel so much better it makes you
slightly bulletproof you still need
other people we all need other people
but the dialoguing with yourself and
starting with I'm enough
I picked that because I found all my
clients addicts binges bulimics
saboteurs hoarders compulsive compulsive
shoplifters they all went back to the
same thing I'm not enough
I need more and if you feel enough
you start to feel equal see most of us
feel unequal you're better than me
because you got money or you're more
attractive than me
but no dog or cat says oh you're better
than me because you're a pedigree a baby
doesn't know that another baby's wearing
designer clothes and they're not they
they have no concept of that so really
what I'm enough is doing is reactivating
re-manifesting and regenerating what you
were born with an ability to say I'm
enough in my experience people who try
to be perfect are the unhappiest people
in the world and they're almost always
the loneliest too when you try to be
perfect you have entered a race that you
can't win you can't even complete it
there is no Finishing Line the Finishing
Line keeps moving so when you're in a
race to be thinner happier richer more
successful you can't complete that race
you can't win it instead of thinking oh
I'm reaching my goals you feel intense
dissatisfaction here's the truth the way
you feel about everything is down to the
pictures you make in your head and the
words you say to yourself and guess what
is so great you can change those
pictures anytime you can change those
words every thought you think
every word you say becomes a blueprint
that your mind body and psyche use
everything at their disposal to make
real thoughts are things what you speak
and think and say without realizing your
mind is working so hard to make that
your reality even if it's super negative
you know I see parents all the time who
say things like I'll be happy when my
kids sleep through the night I'd be
happy with my kids out of diapers I'll
be happy when my kid is walking feeding
themselves going to school and they
spend their whole child's life looking
at the next bit to be happy when you
should be thinking wow I wish every
stage took three times as long you waste
your amazing life wishing it away for
the next bit because happiness is not a
destination you arrive at it's the
journey on it's an inside job do not
Farm out I'll be happy when because
there is no terminal to get to good
happiness happiness is a journey are on
now perfectionists come in all shapes
and sizes and they're often very good at
hiding that inner drive to be perfect
there's one thing that drives them all
an inner belief that says I'm not enough
I'm less than if I'm less than and I can
come across as perfect I'll be more than
you know my neighbors always say to me
wow you have so many famous clients are
they damaged by Fame I'm like no
actually no damaged people are attracted
to fame they have a belief I'm so
damaged but if I'm famous Rich gorgeous
amazing I'll be perfect but you see what
happens when damaged people try to be
perfect
actually damages them more you don't
need to be perfect you don't need to be
Flawless you don't need to be infallible
you just need to be enough and when you
let the fact in that you are enough sort
of trying so hard to be perfect which
you can never achieve when you let in
being enough changes your life so let it
in that you're enough right now because
that's the truth about you people think
the brain is really complicated it's not
it's actually quite simple you only need
to know three things about your brain to
always get what you want and the first
thing is your brain does exactly
what it thinks you want it to do because
it listens to everything you say so when
you say things like oh God you know I
got dumped it was so painful I never
want to go through that again oh your
mind can pick up is you you don't want
to be in a relationship again when
people have a miscarriage and go I could
never never go through that again I'd
rather die than go through that again
your mind is speaking up oh right well
that's that's a statement that's
actually a command to me to make sure
you never go through miscarriage again
and that that's how you get unexplained
infertility
which is something else I've been
working on a lot recently because the
mind listens to it says we will go oh I
went on this fly I thought I was going
to die and do it again I'm never getting
a player it's this plane lands I will
never ever get on a plane again and of
course it lands I go it was just
turbulence but next time they go to the
airport of a massive panic attack
because your mind's like hang on a
minute you said I never want to fly
again
and so if you haven't got what you want
it's because you're giving your mind
very confusing messages your mind's
number one job is to listen to what you
say and to interact on it the second job
is to move you towards pleasure and away
from Pain and it will always always do
more to avoid pain so let's imagine
you've gone for an interview you've done
it as a public speech thing like me and
you've stood up you've got a uh uh and
you say oh my God I'm never doing this
again and you'd have a terrible
presentation and one of my clients who
had for Sony was saying that she had to
stand up and just say to Sony this is a
new band from Camden and she stood up
and went this is a new band from
and they're called
I I couldn't do it I just was the
simplest thing and my boss had to take
over and I was explaining to her that
when you do that and go oh my God I
don't want to do it I don't want to do
this again your mind is now going to
make sure you don't do it again so the
next time you go to speak it will give
you a panic attack it'll make you ill
and if you say to yourself oh my God I'd
love a week off in bed or I'm dreading
next Wednesday your mind is so in tune
with you your week off in bed you wake
up with the flu and your mind's like
there you go how cool am I there's your
week in bed you don't want to go to that
speech I've woken you up with diarrhea
so now you can't go
that's what the Mind does when I was
giving my first ever presentation about
my first ever book I woke up with the
most excruciating Mark I've ever had one
before I thought wow I must have been
saying to myself so I don't want to do
this because I've got this migraine and
I actually went and did it and I didn't
have the migraine until I stepped back
off the stage again and I realized that
I was communicating very badly with
myself so you must never say nervous say
excited because your mind listens so
those three things are your mind does
what it really thinks you want to do if
you're very very specific and say I want
this and this I want to be a great
speaker I want to deliver things I want
to be fantastic at sales I want to be
able to look through an eye and sell
them things and come across as really
authentic
your mind will understand and if you
make those pictures really good
and pleasant you'll move towards them
when there is a battle between logic and
emotion emotion always always always
wins how many of you have gone to a
really high building an enclosed
building like the top story of a hotel
or the CN Tower in Toronto and look down
and thought oh wow I feel really scared
my logic my nose that I'm safe that the
glass is that thick that I can't fall
but the emotion that's making my stomach
Lurch is winning so when you have a
battle between emotion and logic emotion
always always always wins here's
something you all know we can all ring
our friend and go I'm a bit bored a bit
lonely can I hang out or I'm a bit bored
let's go to the movie you would never
ring someone you've just met and go I'm
bored and lonely will you come and hang
out with me let's go to the movie
because the emotion that you might be
reject will overrule the logic that says
this person may be the person for me so
if you're having a battle between
yourself here's a great one I know I
shouldn't eat cake that's the logic but
the emotion is oh the cake feels so good
in this creamy sugary stuff reminds me
of being a baby when all my needs were
met by having creamy sugary stuff so in
a battle doing emotion and logic logic
will never win emotion will always win
and you can make that Win For You by
making it a better emotion so here's how
to do it here's an emotion I'm scared to
ask for a pay rise in case my boss
laughs me out of the office make it a
stronger emotion if I go to my boss and
show them what I've done how valuable I
am that won't happen here's an emotion I
really want to ask that person on a date
I'm not good enough
change the emotion I'm wonderful I'm
amazing what could I get from asking
someone on a date that says yes so much
and if they say no I'm only exactly
where I was before except I've been
brave I've done something courageous
I've taken action even if it doesn't
work out I've lost nothing but I've
gained courage so when you're having a
battle doing logic and emotion emotion
always wins logic never wins that's why
you could stand on the windowsill of
your apartment if it was on the ground
floor but you would never stand on the
Windows there same size if it was a
hundred stories out because the emotion
that you may for defeat the logic that
says I can do this when it's a few feet
off the ground why can't I do it up here
because emotion
overalls logic you can make your life
phenomenal extraordinary and wonderful
by always using emotion to defeat
emotion every baby on the world is worn
loaded with self-esteem no baby when
they're being pushed down the street in
their stroller goes oh don't look at me
I'm having a bad hair day or I've just
been sick on my little Romper suit or I
got really fat legs babies first
experience on the planet is being looked
at when you're born the doctor the nurse
the Midwife look at you family come to
visit you you get your picture taken
people show you off and babies don't
avert their eyes when you take their
picture
when I used to push my little girl down
the street looking her pram go oh my God
she's so gorgeous she never looked away
she kicked her little legs she gave a
big gummy smile because she knew that
she was gorgeous too and if you ever
doubt that children like attention
go to a park
go to a swimming pool in your hair every
chugging mummy mummy look at me on the
swing Daddy watch me on the slide mummy
mummy watch me jump in the wood Watch Me
swim watch me jump because children have
this belief that I'm worthy of attention
and I like it and I can ask for it and
I'll get it then you have to ask well
where does that go well it goes very
fast you know if I said to my little
girl look to sing mummy a song she would
sing if I said 14 sing me a song she'd
roll her eyes and go my God you're so
embarrassing and walk out of the room
because at a very early age we acquire a
fear of being judges what is called
performance anxiety what if I sing and
someone laughs at me what if I read in
class and I get it wrong what if I stand
up to speak and I don't know what to say
and performance and anxiety can be so
intense that it makes this stop
performing but people who perform really
well like themselves well I'll see what
happens and I'll sing our dance I'll act
I mean some people can't even dance at a
party in case everyone is looking at
them
and judging them badly some of my
clients won't even go to yoga in case
they can't hold the poses like everyone
else and believe me we're all so busy
worrying about ourselves we don't have
time to look at you and
comment on your yoga position or how
you're dancing at a party and we kind of
like people who don't care who just let
go and have a good time
so the thing you need to have phenomenal
confidence really are two things stop
judging yourself
and be nice to yourself here's my advice
to you expect amazing things then if
what is expected tends to be realized
expect the best expect love and success
and an amazing life because you know
what it will probably be realized really
fast if you expect it because you made
it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there